losing half your assets so we have an
entire system that is trying to take
your you know where the women are
actually paid to take your ship now
we're going to talk about ways to
mitigate the risk later but let's just
let's just look at what could what is
the worst thing that could happen to you
another risk is your kids hate you now
I've talked to women and men that hated
their fathers for years based off of
information that their mother told them
talking about their dad and a lot
of these kids that hate their parents
were actually from two parent home
imagine with a divorce which is half of
them right so that's a risk that even if
you have a legacy it's really like the
kid could hate you you get divorced she
has custody